ça fait trente deux épisodes que je vous
parle de la démocratie étudié sous
l'angle de la théorie des jeux on a
étudié en long en large et en travers et
ça fait un petit peu beaucoup
d'informations du coup ça serait bon de
tout récapituler histoire de mieux
comprendre comment tout cela se combine
et puis aussi comme ça si vous voulez
motiver un ami à regarder toute cette
série vous pour être peut-être lui
conseillé de commencer par cette vidéo
alors si je devais résumer cette série
en un mot ça sera le mot incentive
on peut parfois traduire par intérêt ou
par incitatif plus généralement les
incentives c'est ce que les gens ont
intérêt à faire étant donné le contexte
et leurs préférences individuelles
le message clé de cette série c'est que
nous sous-estimons constamment
l'importance des incentives et que
beaucoup de choses en politique en
économie en sociologie mais aussi en
éthique et en morale ne peuvent être
compris qu est la lumière des incentives
les incentives uns et des autres
conduisent à un jeu entre politiciens
entreprises ou citoyens et c'est
incentives peuvent être incompatible
avec le bonheur général
or plus les incentives sont grands plus
ce seront eux qui gouverneront les
interactions humaines comme l'affirment
le grand sociologue squeeze maintenant
la coupe lutte au final ce qu'il faut
retenir de tout ça ce que le jeu est
défini ce que les joueurs vont faire on
a ainsi vu que les scrutins un pic un
jeu entre politiciens en particulier des
scrutins uninominaux à un tour et à deux
tours ainsi que les scrutin à la
proportionnelle encourage les
politiciens à s'organiser sous forme de
partie à cause d'une propriété appelée
la dépendance aux alternatives non
pertinentes
pire encore ces scrutins pose un dilemme
du vote utile aux citoyens si bien que
les résultats du scrutin ne sont pas
forcément révélateur des vrais
préférence des citoyens on a aussi vu
que dans lequel de l'élection d'une
seule alternative
il y avait des théorèmes d'impossibilité
qui montrait la difficulté du choix du
scrutin mais aussi qu'il existait deux
scrutins inventé récemment avec de biens
meilleures propriétés que les scrutins
utilisé aujourd'hui savoir jugement
majoritaire et le scrutin de condorcet a
randomisé l'utilisation de ces scrutins
réduire voire ferait disparaître tout
dilemme du vote utile augmenterait le
pouvoir d'expression des citoyens au
moment du vote et éliminerait les
principaux incentives à l'organisation
des politiciens sous forme de parti
politique
ces politiciens justement on a tendance
à penser qu'il s'agit
loups assoiffés de pouvoir selon les
puissants modèles de mesquita c'est
essentiellement le cas mais
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
naïvement
ceci ne veut pas dire qu'ils vont agir
tel des méchants aux dépens des pauvres
et du gentil peuple et encore moins qui
sont aveuglés par le pouvoir au point de
prendre des décisions toutes plus
débiles les unes que les autres
non selon le modèle de mesquita les
politiciens sont avant tout de fin
tacticien et leurs stratégies vont donc
s'aligner avec leur incentives
or en démocratie pour être et rester au
pouvoir les politiciens ou tout intérêt
à gagner le coeur des citoyens est donc
à prendre des mesures qui plairont à la
majorité alors les mauvaises langues
diront qu'il s'agit de populisme mais il
faut surtout voir qu'il s'agit d'une
certaine forme de démocratie puisque les
décisions des politiques seront alors
bel et bien fonction de la volonté
populaire en tout cas dans la mesure où
cette volonté populaire et marquer alors
à ce que c'est une bonne chose
répondre à cette question difficile nous
a fallu définir le bien et le distinguer
du mal ou plutôt du moins bien autrement
dit on a dû étudier la morale est là il
faut distinguer deux types de morale y
lé moral dit prescriptive ou normative
qui propose des principes ou des
finalités désirable et les morales dit
descriptive ou prédictive qui cherche à
décrire et a expliqué l'immoral
intuitive des citoyens on a vu que les
sciences modernes considère que les
morales intuitive sont les fruits de
l'évolution darwinienne et en
particulier n'ont survécu que les
morales intuitive qui ont triomphé dans
la compétition entre morale d'individus
autrement dit même notre moral intuitive
est une réponse à des incentives on a vu
en particulier la théorie de la
sélection de groupes défendue notamment
par le psychologue jonathan wright cette
théorie postule que notre moral
intuitive sert à consolider nos groupes
et à donner envie aux membres du groupe
de se soulever irrationnellement pour la
défense des leurs autrement dit notre
moral intuitive et l'hooliganisme en
faveur des nôtres et celle ci est
exacerbée par les symboles qui identifie
les groupes auxquels on appartient
et parce qu'ils identifient les groupes
auxquels on s'oppose
c'est ainsi que l'on a un attachement
irrationnelle en des principes ou des
concepts puisque nos groupes sacralise
comme la marseillaise
démocratie le travail la religion la
laïcité la liberté l'égalité où la
nation selon john brennan cette
hooliganisme c'est ce qui nous abrutit
une cour on lorsqu'on s'intéresse à la
politique
il anéantit nos capacités cognitives et
nos compétences mathématiques amplifie
tout nos biens cognitif à coups de
raisonnement motivés et de
rationalisation et nous fait tendre vers
l'extrémisme
quand on est confronté à des avis
concordants or selon brian caplanne la
démocratie favorise l'hooliganisme
politique
en effet parce qu'en démocratie chaque
vote n'a essentiellement aucun effet
line sent-il des citoyens est d'éternuer
leur hooliganisme plutôt que de dépenser
du temps et de l'énergie pour effectuer
un vote informé inutile selon caplanne
en démocratie les citoyens sont
rationnellement irrationnelle et
pourtant on aurait pu espérer que
l'accès à de l'information fiable via
wikipedia et les technologies du
numérique résolve le problème de
l'ignorance des citoyens oise
malheureusement il semble que le web n'a
fait qu'empirer l'hooliganisme des
citoyens et là encore ceci peut se
comprendre en analysant les incentives
des citoyens en particulier le biais de
confirmation combinée à la facilité du
choix des sources que permet internet a
conduit les citoyens similaire à se
rapprocher sur internet
or ce rapprochement qui peut pas être
innocent à l'échelle individuelle
conduit à une ségrégation idéologique
massive à l'échelle du web c'est la
ségrégation de chai ling
pire encore la vitesse à laquelle les
idéologies peuvent être partagées sur
internet a favorisé les idéologies
virale autrement dit pour gagner en
influence les incentives des idéologies
et de leurs auteurs consiste à activer
l'hooliganisme de leurs victimes en
suscitant la fascination la peur et la
colère et en s'opposant à des idéologies
ennemis incompatibles les nouvelles
technologies ont exacerbé l'hooliganisme
pour combattre cet oubli ganis
il est indispensable à ne pas se
restreindre à notre vision du monde
il est indispensable de chercher à aussi
voir le monde tel que les autres le
voient
et oui parce qu'au moment de prendre une
décision les autres sont dans un
contexte différent et ont des
préférences individuelles différentes
les incentives des uns ne sont pas les
mêmes que les incentives des autres et
c'est pour ça que j'aime pas trop les
mots intérêts et incitatif parce qu'il
donne l'impression qu'on a tous les
mêmes intérêts et qu'on réagit de la
même façon aux incitatifs
d'ailleurs cette absence de prise en
compte de la divergence des incentive
des uns et des autres c'est quelque
chose que l'on retrouve notamment dans
la règle d'or et plus généralement dans
les morales déontologique par opposition
d'autres philosophie morale normative
ils intègrent dans leur philosophie les
divergences des incentives des
différentes personnes c'est le cas de la
proche utilitariste de la philosophie
morale
même si on est d'accord pour dire
qu'elle a ses imperfections selon
l'utilitarisme une action est bonne si
parmi l'ensemble des actions qui étaient
possibles à ce moment là il s'agit de
celle qui maximise le bonheur général et
ce qui est très intrigant avec cette
morale simpliste c'est qu'il suffit pour
remettre en cause beaucoup de principes
ou de moyens qui nous sont chers comme
la règle d'or qui dit qu'il faut traiter
autrui comme on souhaiterait être traité
comme la nécessité de créer toujours
plus de job pour plus de gens et comme
le principe même de démocratie en fait
le concept le plus important à retenir
de cette série c'est peut-être celui
d'hooliganisme politique lequel est
parfaitement illustrée par notre
organisme démocratique et pour ceux qui
croient qu'il s'agit d'un concept fumeux
je conseille cette superbe vidéo de
frédéric garcia qui suggère que l'eau
liga ni sme politique correspond à
l'utilisation d'une certaine partie de
votre cerveau et je pense que si vous
cherchez à être attentifs à votre
organisme vous vous sentirez que ça
typiquement on a tous envie de dire que
démocratie c'est bien et que si une
décision est prise de façon
antidémocratique
alors il s'agit nécessairement d'une
mauvaise décision
cependant cet argument ne tient que si
on prend pour actions que la démocratie
est bien de façon intrigante pour
l'utilité est restée il ne s'agit pas
d'un axiome en fait utilitariste
considèrent que la démocratie n'est bien
que dans les cas où elle maximise le
bonheur général
or en pratique c'est loin d'être
toujours le cas sur wikipédia comme dans
le monde de la recherche
la proche et piste aux pratiques
semblent bien plus utilitariste que les
décisions démocratiques et il ya fort à
parier que sur de nombreuses décisions
nécessitant une expertise
au final c'est le cas de la plupart des
débats de société d'aujourd'hui
notamment pourvu que la séparation des
expertises et appliqué il s'agira d'un
devoir moral pour l'utilitaire east que
de contourner la démocratie même si
cette conclusion des plaies alou ligue
démocratique en nous ouah ça fait
beaucoup de choses avec 1 minute 30 deux
épisodes dans cette série néanmoins il
ne faut pas perdre de vue l'étendue de
notre ignorance
il ya énormément d'anglais d' analyse
pertinente de la démocratie que je n'ai
pas abordé dans cette série mais que
j'aurais aimé avoir présenté j'aurais
aimé aussi vous parler des points de
shillings des théorèmes qui formalise le
concept des lecteurs médian des
mathématiques du vote électroniques
cryptés du problème de l'anonymisation
des données personnelles des difficultés
de la formalisation du concept de
discrimination des impacts de l'économie
sur les systèmes politiques mises en
place et notamment une superbe vidéo de
sidi pigrée qui suggère que la
démocratie est une conséquence de la
révolution industrielle plus que d'un
triomphe du peuple et des philosophes
des lumières
j'aurais aimé vous avoir parlé de la
décentralisation de la monnaie avec le
bitcoin notamment de la charismatique
rassis dans laquelle on vit qui consiste
à donner plus de pouvoir à des gens qui
ont du charisme des jeux de localisation
qui explique pourquoi les kebabs sont
souvent tous ou même endroit de la
purification de ars à nîmes pour
comprendre l'utilité des probabilités
bayésienne pour comprendre des équipes
mixtes de la théorie algorithmique des
jeux qui se demande si les marchés sont
vraiment capables de jouer en équipe de
nash de la programmation dynamique qui
montre que les futurs probables
détermine le présent des jeux h au mien
qui montre que même dans des populations
de taille infinie comportement du groupe
se déduit encore et toujours des
incentives individuel ou encore des
lézards de californie qui montre que
dame nature est capable de calculer des
équilibres de nage
et puis j'aurais aimé vous avoir
longuement parlé des théories de
machiavel pour qui le devoir moral ne
réside pas dans la bonté des intentions
mais dans l'efficacité des actions
ça fait encore beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à explorer pour comprendre la
démocratie mais comme certains parmi
vous est un petit peu envie de passer à
autre chose
donc malheureusement la série s'arrête
ça j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu et
qu'elle vous aura fait réfléchir et
j'espère que vous allez lutter contre
votre hooliganisme lors des prochains
débats politiques que vous allez avoir
etc avant d'affirmer que x est la
solution à tous vos problèmes vous
prendrez le temps de mesurer l'étendue
de votre ignorance et que vous éviterez
ainsi de tomber en excès de confiance